I guess all Americans have a favorite
period of American history.
Uh,
mine is the period of the founding
fathers.
Uh,
I've really been quite enchanted by
them.
We were a very small country,
four or 5 million people,
but we produced in a period of a few
years a flowering of political changes.
Just remarkable,
I think unprecedented really in the
history of the world.
And I like all of them.
I guess I've read a good bit about them,
the giants.
But my particular favorite is,
uh,
James Madison.
Uh,
Madison of course did not have all that
successful,
the tenure as president,
but he was the father of the
constitution.
And I've been a kind of attracted to him
because I've always felt that he,
uh,
he could never have gotten elected to
Congress.
He was a small man about five foot tall.
He had a pockmarked face.
He was a lousy speaker,
uh,
on television.
He'd had been a disaster.
Uh,
but he was a political genius because he
was able to,
uh,
put together,
if you would,
large portions of the constitution.
So my interest has really been with the
founding fathers.
I have others.
I admire Lincoln of course,
like all Americans I admire.
Uh,
but the founding fathers,
I,
I feel a deep,
deep sense of appreciation for,
uh,
because of what they did.
Uh,
the question I would repeatedly get when
I was conducting public meetings in
Indiana was where the leaders,
it's the question you just asked and I
think it's a hundred minds of an awful
lot of Americans.
Where are the Lincolns,
the Jeffersons,
the Washingtons?
I don't know that I know the answer to
that,
but I think part of the answer may be
that the country is just a lot more
complicated,
a lot more difficult to govern today
because of its size and because of its
diversity,
because of the acceleration if you would
have life,
uh,
and the political skill that is most
needed in this presidential election or
any political election from my point of
view is the ability to build consensus
behind a solution.
It's not very hard really to walk into a
room of people where you're discussing a
difficult issue and blow it apart.
I know it's not very hard because I've
done it on a few occasions.
What is really hard is to walk into that
room and to build a consensus behind a
solution to the problem that you're
talking about.
That is political skill and that is the
skill most needed in this great big,
diverse,
complicated country with all of these
conflicting interests that we have
consensus building.
That's what I look for in a politician.
I think we've got a lot of work to do.
Uh,
I think we've had quite a setback and we
have not used that power as wisely and
prudently and effectively as we should
have used it,
particularly with regard to the war in
Iraq.
But this is behind us now and we've got,
we are where we are.
We can't change recent events and recent
history.
So I think we have to apply American
power pragmatically.
Uh,
realistically,
uh,
we have to make sure that
we do not set goals for ourselves that
we cannot achieve.
When President Bush said we're going to
end tyranny in the world,
uh,
that is idealism beyond reach.
When President Kennedy said,
we must bear any burden,
uh,
that is beyond reach.
It's an ideal,
but the problem is matching resources to
achieve your goals.
And Americans I think have tended to
overreach in the world and to think that
our power is so great that we can
achieve all kinds of things.
Uh,
I have become impressed with the
limitations of American power and with
the necessity of matching our goals with
the means to achieve those goals and to
apply for ourselves pragmatic objectives
around the world,
achievable objectives and to,
to think that we can suddenly make
democracy bloom in Saudi Arabia and
Egypt and Pakistan,
uh,
is is a stretch.
We can't do it,
but I'm also impressed that American
ideals are good and solid,
but we cannot accomplish them without a
lot of help.
If you sit down and try to name the most
difficult problems that bother you.
I don't know what it might be.
A climate change,
drugs,
uh,
conflicts of all kinds,
rising tensions in the world,
uh,
HIV aids,
whatever,
nuclear proliferation,
you have to be impressed,
I think with the fact that you cannot
achieve those goals by yourself.
We have to have held as big as we are,
as smart as we are,
as rich as we are.
We need help and we have to learn to
work together.
The great
genius of American diplomacy,
uh,
came about it,
at least in my lifetime after World War
II,
when the idealism of the American people
was captured pragmatically and we
rebuilt Europe with the Marshall Plan.
Europeans leading the way of course,
but with our health and we had this
flowering of diplomacy,
the World Bank,
the IMF,
what eventually came,
became the WTO,
the World Trade Organization of the
United Nations.
In other words,
we,
we advanced American interests,
but we did it by cooperating with other
countries around the world.
We did not say this is the way it's
going to be.
It's going to be the American model.
We're going to do it our way.
We're going to impose it upon you.
We rejected that and we took the
generosity of the American public.
Just think for a moment.
We defeated Japan and Germany.
They were the great evil at all.
Fiddler Tojo.
Some people were,
remember that the emperor of Japan,
after the war,
we immediately turned around immediately
and gave aid to those countries.
What a remarkable thing to think of that
we gave aid to the people we had been
fighting for years.
Well,
how do you capture that spirit again,
that generosity,
that pragmatism,
that ability to advance your interest,
but also include the interest of others?
That's the great challenge for us.
Uh,
you'd have to say leadership.
I believe.
You'd have to say that.
Uh,
we've lost a little bit of that
imagination,
uh,
that are,
predecessors had after World War II.
We lack their generosity of spirit
there.
Magnanimity uh,
we've got to try to recapture that.
If we,
if we're really going to be the leader
of the world,
we can't sit down at the international
conference table and say,
okay,
this is the agenda.
We're going to dictate the agenda.
We've got to sit down at that table and
promote our agenda,
whatever it may be,
fighting terrorism or whatever.
But we've also got to sit there and
listen to what the other side has to
say.
Don't necessarily have to agree with it,
don't have to make a lot of concessions,
but you do have to try to learn to
understand it,
to accommodate it if possible.
And if not defined areas where you can
agree and work on those where you cannot
agree.